videos and we're excited to announce  that yes Skyrim is coming to the  Nintendo switch  [Music]  we love to make games and worlds that  you can get lost in that you can make  your own and that you never want to put  down  [Music]  well now you don't have to now you can  play Skyrim wherever you want and take  it on your own adventures what's really  exciting is for all of us at Bethesda to  finally work with Nintendo  you look at all they've done for video  games over the decades they've brought  so much innovation and fun to all of us  and they're doing it again the switch is  both classically Nintendo yet something  all-new and we want to thank them for  letting us be a part thank you